[Music]
the hell is the goddess of death and
I've had incredible fun playing her oh
I've missed this tell us the first
female villain that we've had in a
Marvel film and Kate has destroyed the
idea of your typical villain kneel
before your Queen loved working with
Cate Blanchett I was so excited to see
what she was gonna do hello as this
insane off-kilter attitude you know like
a smart boy how would you like a job
I think the best villains are always
those that you kind of love and hate
what they do but you sort of understand
it there's a logic to it she wants to
come back home and be accepted and she
wants what says you're in my seat I
would love for someone else to rule but
it can't be you you're just the worst
some of the happiest times have been
fading people out I've really enjoyed us
like I don't speak today I can just
throw axes in - someone's got good
[Music]
so much has happened since I last saw
you I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh but then I
went on a journey of self-discovery
I love you
[Music]
well you have no idea
I love the goddess of death is invaded
as God oh I miss this
and you and I had a fight news they did
I won
now I want easily doesn't sound right
well that's true
as God is dead it'll be reborn in my
image I thought you'd be glad to see me
need a stopper here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
like the old days
[Music]
surprise this is such fun
he's a fighter
we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
we're the same you and I just a couple
of hotheaded fools
yes say I'll collect fire door like
water mama kind of both like fire
butthole like raging fire so I like
smoldering fire
[Music]
and